so good afternoon I'd like to thank the
organizers for the invitation and thank
you ian the teaching of topics related
to to heritage preservation in Brazil
became mandatory in architectural
courses as of 1994 until then it
appeared occasionally in undergraduate
courses in a more structured way own in
graduate school our school is divided in
three departments design technology and
history which in time have become more
and more autonomous the formation of our
architects sent to be fragmented and few
are the experiences that engage more
than one field in the Department of
History in 2005 there was a
reformulation of the curriculum
framework which included the creation of
a compulsory course geared specifically
to cultural heritage of a fundamentally
historical critical nature preservation
becomes increasingly relevant in
architectural education due to the
expansion expansion of what's considered
cultural heritage which went from the
isolated moment monument chaves areas
covering variety assets belonging to a
past closer and closer towards the
current course on preservation aims to
raise our awareness among students and
provide critical tools to understand the
problems involved it seeks to
characterize preservation as a field
that has its own theoretical
methodological and technical frame
frameworks but necessarily works
combining verified fields of knowledge
encompassing both exact and Natural
Sciences sciences and all how also
humanities in the introduction of the
course some questions are presented the
reasons that led us to in to be
interested in cultural heritage design
challenges concepts and terminology
involved then some of the problems
related to Brazil spoke policies of
preservation over time our faith
the emphasis of the course however is
placed on the transformation of
theoretical principles over the
centuries these principles are closely
related to the reasons that motivate us
to probe to preserve cultural heritage
mainly of cultural scientific scientific
and ethical nature the aim is to show
that existing of a conceptual basis
emphasizing the need for
multidisciplinary work so that the
interventions are socially and
historically grounded geared to a
preservation that respects the past and
is focused on the present always keeping
the future in the horizon of its
concerns the themes are introduced in
order to sensitize students in many of
our schools of architecture there is a
Steaua tendency to form architects who
believe they have full creative autonomy
and who tends as Roberto bunny have said
in the 1960s to assert the coat of
personality and social irresponsibility
therefore one of the courses emphasis is
to provide the ethical basis for
consistent professional practice the
discipline however due to the school
structure cannot work with design and
technological solutions covered by other
departments recognizing that a
fragmented approach does not favor the
awareness of the need of the
interdisciplinary work a new
inter-department elective course was
created the courses meant to make
students work coordinate Lee in face of
conceptual technical and design issues
addressing in each exercise a specific
problem you can see some of the results
in the following slides in these first
editions of the discipline exercise were
centered in building of the fat in the
buildings of the faculty two of them
protected by state and municipal law the
fact that the students use these
buildings makes the questions more
concrete and immediate with them they
must to face the problems mobilize
knowledge and
nationals of different areas such as
engineering biology chemistry history
and sociology the various disciplines
involved do not necessarily have a
harmonious view of a given issue most of
the time there are conflicts it's very
important to learn to dialogue
understand the different motivations and
seek together a solution that is
acceptable take into consideration the
various perspective thank you for your
attention